ein jahr bei der begrüßung richtig
verändert operierte bevor es wieder
losgeht wird immer schnell loswerden
kleinen fertigten april den drei tagen
von köln über treffen in wien
stattfindet alle links und infos dazu
kennen die in der beschreibung gibt
sogar noch den korb mit dem wir über
mich fünf euro kräftig im programmheft
ich hoffe wir sehen uns dort wird weiter
neuen video herzlich willkommen zum
heutigen video ihr erinnert euch
vielleicht noch vor geraumer zeit hat
sich der eine der mutigen über ein
youtube video gemacht hast noch niemals
ganz youtube die rede ist von 310 und
eigentlich fertig wenige trade los
angeles gesehen leute letztes mal was
schwierig vielleicht gewinnt verlinkt
ich habe gerade noch mal aber dieses mal
richtig schwere batterie lädt gemerkt
hat beim letzten mal nicht gut immer ein
bisschen schwach wenn es um reck ging
und heute machen wir die challenge und
nur rap drin
die regeln sind ganz klar man darf nicht
kannten man versuchen gruben oder sowas
man darf mich mit dingen das sowieso und
das schwierig wenn man da auch nicht im
cockpit sing ich glaube das wird
ziemlich schwierig übrigens die nächsten
videos werden wieder nicht reaktion
sondern irgendwie eigene aber moment mal
bevor wir loslegen meinem trainer track
trace muss ich ein bisschen gebraucht
werden okay leute ich würde sagen die
transformation ist auf jeden fall
geglückt und
[Musik]
es ist mal richtig schwierig für mich in
dem ich musik auch richtig laut mache
oder ich fühle
[Musik]
das dort fühlt man einfach oder
das ist einfach so ich fühle irgendwie
so am meisten gebraucht schreibt email
meine kommentare was eure lieblingsmusik
richtung ist wie immer auch geschafft
habt oder nicht weil vor
[Musik]
okay da war heute mein erstes ernst
gemacht hat man so ein video gemacht
erstes mal challenge ist es wo ich fünf
oder zehn sachen gemacht habe ich noch
nie gemacht habe eine sache davon war
ein richtiges musici unterfalle zu
diesem lied gemacht und danach kann
diese der ski challenge ein schöner
vergessen wo also stehen bleiben
das gleicht ein wenig schlauer 10.000
werk wenn ich richtig schlau wiederum
10.000 gleich nicht und leute verliert
sie dann
moment alfons weshalb er in seiner hand
es sind vier fünf leute nicht mit mir
bei so einer betrügerischen kacke ring
ich sicherlich nicht mit ja irgendwie so
in die seite zu locken
so zum beispiel das einsenden kann kein
abend bisher gemacht habe wahrscheinlich
ist darunter
[Musik]
ich will mich nicht ich will es nicht
aber in koch trotzdem ist eigentlich hab
ich irgendwie auftaktgefecht parat und
wie wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin so im kopf
mit sich
das ist das noch direkt im bus passiert
sein
post meldet neuer rapper liebe zweier
aber mit allen aufgefallen
die feier von den sachen aber vor allem
feiert so aus gezeugt und tagesgeld an
das ist noch schwieriger
[Musik]
okay gab es mit dieser kirche los
gewinnt vielleicht trage freiminuten
oder so was sagte die leute darauf dass
gorleben telefon sollte aber trotzdem
ich glaube noch schwieriger für mich
wird trainer politischen das video gibt
nur drei minuten deshalb ziemlich
schnell rein und durchlaufen
[Musik]
ich weiß es nicht vielmehr so die
kopfnicker somit könnt ihr verstehen
[Musik]
durchgefallen war nur aktion findet noch
ein bisschen wird weil man halt nicht so
viel redet dabei wir sehen uns beim
nächsten video wieder bis dahin und
traktoren lieblingsrestaurant in die
kommentare auch wenn ich noch dran
bleiben